Okay.
So I'm going to show you guys,
yeah,
totally relevant.
Everyone here.
Um,
for future offering,
can we still send it to Christine
because she's not here?
I can't ask her that.
Assuming the best.
Okay.
No,
if we should send it,
I will as soon as I find out,
but I suspect that things will go on as
normal.
So just do what we've been doing.
That's the theory
factors yesterday,
I think.
Yeah.
I don't think she is.
Can you be on strike you like shame on
you for being straight cause you're not
here.
I just feel like,
yeah.
I'm just wondering,
could you be on strike if you're pointed
to another?
Well they're near on a virtual strike.
What's that?
What's that office.
Okay,
well I'll,
should we sign all the stupid things.
I can't send her the damn essays and
we'll see what happens or in the future
or three stuff.
Eventually they're going to get graded.
If they don't,
I will figure out what to do about it.
You're not going to be left hanging with
this course.
Okay,
so just do the word,
do the work.
We'll figure out how you get your damn
credit.
I'm going to do everything I can so that
you're not left hanging because I don't
think that's reasonable.
You know,
did the beef isn't with you guys.
So,
um,
so don't worry about it for now.
Just proceed as if everything will be
worked out.
Okay.
So I want to show you some images and
these are great farther images
fundamentally.
And I want you to take a look at them
because they're powerful propaganda
images and we want to see what they
represent.
So on the right,
you see Hitler there?
Who's taking over from,
yeah,
Hindenburg I believe that's right.
Okay.
I can't remember.
He was the president before Hitler came,
came aboard.
And so you see that there's the transfer
of power from the wise old man to the,
to the emergent hero.
That's the image on the left.
Right?
And so then on the right,
well,
so what do you think about that picture?
What does it represent?
What's going on there?
What's that?
Yeah,
we'll just look at,
just look at the image.
I think it's the balance of representing
the big order,
the balance between tyranny.
MMM
turney and security,
security.
It's the balance be doing all the Cyrus
and horace,
right?
It's different than that.
That's close.
But you know,
it's a call to heroism from the youth
with the father who's far seeing and you
know,
composed serving as the protector and
the model.
So.
Yup.
No,
that's your sort of ideal area in youth.
Yeah,
and it's an interesting picture,
a because it's,
it's actually a picture that represents
a child in a way that you very seldom
see children represented.
You know,
because the child is very serious and
determined and you know,
that's not an acceptable image of a
child.
Generally speaking in a culture that's
optimistic and naive because the kids
are always like their little innocent
things that have no power.
It's like that's wrong.
Yes,
definitely.
Oh,
He's a great father.
He's the all seeing great farther in the
background.
He's like the wizard of Oz
fundamentally.
You know?
So,
yeah.
Yeah.
So these partly order,
and that was a huge part of Hitler,
and that's partly was attractive because
Germany was absolutely in chaos.
So that made order more and more
attractive.
Right?
So when Hitler was a very orderly
person,
so
and so what does that mean?
Why would that be the case?
That's right.
Right.
So,
so that means they're above you.
You're looking up at an ideal.
Right.
And that's because they're in the
dominance hierarchy.
You're kneeling,
that's another way of thinking about it.
Yes.
There are also lift from above.
And it's far seeing right there looking
far ahead into the future.
That's right.
That's good.
All right.
So then there's the picture on the left.
So what do you think about that?
Yeah.
Oh,
well,
maybe I can make it a little bit bigger.
What you have is Hitler on the right of
the picture in the left,
and then a huge number of people crowded
around him and they're all smiling and,
and joyful.
And so that's a representation of Hitler
as the jovial farther of the race.
Right?
And you'll see it set at a,
at a table.
And what do people do at a table?
Yeah,
that's right.
And they share it.
Right.
And so that's a very familial,
um,
that's a very familial enterprise.
And to share food with someone is to
bring them into your house.
Right.
And to be the distributor of food is to
be the benevolent father.
And then on the right,
you see Hitler addressing,
um,
I large political crowd.
You know,
he's up on a high platform with his men
behind him,
and then these,
these eagles carrying the swastika sort
of arrayed behind him.
So he's up again.
So very good at theatrically.
The Nazis were very good at using
theatrical.
Yeah.
So then you see him on the left there.
What do you think about that picture?
Yeah,
it's Stoic and resolute,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Okay.
And then you have the middle picture
where the Germans are basically marching
with what are really remade Roman
banners,
you know?
And so what do you,
what do you,
what does that image show
very?
Yes,
that's exactly right.
It shows uniformity and solidarity and
the uniformity comes out because
everyone's the same.
Right?
And that makes them a powerful united
force.
Now you might ask yourself,
well,
why would people want that?
And so what's the answer to that
and power,
I mean,
you want to be part of a,
like a powerful united force or do you
want to be like the weak member of an if
completely fragmented society,
you know,
so now you might say,
well I don't want to be too integrated,
but you know,
one thing I would say is don't
overestimate the degree to which you
don't want to be too integrated.
Cause you know,
modern people,
especially in the west,
they like to think of themselves as
individuals.
It's like I have a hypothesis about
that.
I think people in the West are actually
the most conforming people in the entire
world.
Okay.
And that's why they can sort of dance
around on top of that pr like they're
free.
And the reason is everyone stops at the
red lights,
you know,
everyone obeys everything virtually.
And so you can dress weirdly and maybe
you can have a bizarre opinion and you
can go off and do something that's a
little out of the ordinary in some
corner,
but 99% of the time you're a conformist
right to the damn bone.
And that's a good thing because if you
weren't,
the society wouldn't be so stable and so
predictable across,
you know,
reasonable spans of time.
So,
but the idea that the west is
individualistic,
it's like we might represent
individualism as a form of daddy and
aspire to it and we might even worship
it when it occurs because we do with
celebrities and so forth.
But that's by boat.
By no means reasonable to assume that
the west is primarily individualistic.
You know,
I mean,
I grew up in western Canada and in
Edmonton,
if there's a light that's red,
like if you know you're supposed to not
walk,
people will stand there on the street
when it's 40 below and wait until the
light changes.
Even if they can't see your car anywhere
near in any direction.
Like it was quite shocking to me when I
first moved to Montreal.
And people were Jay walking,
you know,
I thought God himself was going to
strike me down with if I did it.
You know,
now that the roads are narrow and so
that's part of it.
But,
but montrealers there's definitely a lot
pushier as pedestrians than people in
the west.
And the other thing that's quite
interesting about the west traffic
patterns is that if you're standing on
the road looking like you might want to
cross,
even if it's Jay walk and get a little
stop and let you cross,
it's quite annoying because you just
standing there and it's like,
you know,
five people stop and then you have to
walk across the street just not to
disappoint them.
So you know,
the thing about conformity is it is it,
it makes for a tremendous amount of
stability.
And believe me,
we wouldn't be promoting nonconformity
if everyone was nonconforming.
We'd be thinking,
Hey,
it's time to get this whole thing
conforming quite,
quite tightly.
One of the things I'd been thinking
about Islam lately is that,
you know,
when,
when you,
when you wanted to find a religion,
we determine is a religion religion of
peace or of,
of war.
And you think,
well it might depend on the level of
analysis.
You know,
one of the things that Islam did was
take a society that was very tribal and
fractious and united across a large
portion of territory.
So you know what,
it did that by expanding its domains and
incorporating other people and also
going to war.
So on the fringes of the Islamic
expansion,
there was all sorts of bloodshed and
misery.
But then inside it,
there was this hierarchical organization
of people that were basically only
organized into little bitty tribal
groups before that.
So you might say,
well,
that within the expanding bubble of
influence,
it was peaceful.
And then on the fringes it was violent.
And then you might say,
well,
what does that mean over the long run?
Is that warlike or peaceful?
And I don't really know how to answer
that question,
you know,
because it depends on which angle you're
looking at it from.
You know,
we certainly know that as humanity
aggregated itself into a larger and
larger collectives,
there was a lot of conflict that had to
be had in order for that to occur.
But the consequence,
like you think about our,
our lives at the moment,
the probability that one of you will get
killed by a homicide is,
you know,
it's vanishingly low.
And then you might ask yourself,
well,
how much bloodshed and conflict did that
take in?
Oh,
before everyone was hammered together so
damn tightly that well,
here's another way of looking at it.
Why is it possible for women to have
rights in the West?
Yeah,
I think the answer to that is because
they can go outside without being raped.
So you know,
the whole culture is so damn peaceful
now that it's a woman can present
herself alone,
two strange men and not die as a
consequence of it.
It's like,
okay,
well then you can start talking about
rights.
It's before that.
It's
whatever
you're talking about.
It's not right.
Mostly what it is is protection.
You know,
you have to be protected.
And there's lots of places in the world
where that's still exactly the way it
is.
You know?
I know that even when I was traveling
through Europe years ago,
when the eighties you know,
I traveled with a friend of mine,
a woman and her boyfriend,
and when we went through Italy for
example,
she was blonde.
She was just harassed to death by the
Italian men.
I mean,
not in any,
not in any way.
That was brutal.
I'm sure it does.
So we took her over to Greece as well,
and we went to this place called Patras
and patches had this absolutely weird
celebration that was like the fourth
biggest celebration in the world.
I'd never even heard of it.
And one of the things they do there is
everybody goes on the street with these
plastic bats,
you know,
they're really light plastic.
Pat's the kinds kid would use.
And they were like this big round.
They're plastic was firm enough so that
it was a bat,
but soft enough.
So if you go whack with it in a semi
playful way,
it wasn't going to hurt.
And then everybody also spraying each
other with silly string,
which I thought was an extremely
bizarre,
I mean that stuff was not old.
So like there's a million people out in
the street and everybody's hitting each
other with bats and spraying each other
with silly string.
And this poor girl,
she must be hit like 10,000
times,
you know,
so,
and it wasn't malevolent.
It was playful,
you know,
it had to be,
because when everyone's hitting
everybody else with bats,
it bloody well better state playful,
right?
But the pro,
the thing is is that she couldn't move
with anywhere near the same freedom that
I could move.
And that's only a tiny,
tiny echo of what it would have been
like in many places 500 years ago or a
thousand years ago.
So again,
you know,
there's this basis of absolute
conformity that's a prerequisite to as
freedom,
especially freedom for people who are
vulnerable in many ways.
So that's part of what's being
celebrated in that image.
And you know,
if people are in the state of chaos,
that's one thing that really attracts
them.
They're attracted by order.
And so,
you know,
you always have to give the devil his
due.
If you're trying to understand something
like not see as it,
you have to understand why it might be
attractive to someone like you.
Now the question is in part,
why did it go so pathologically wrong?
Well that's part of what we're going to
untangle,
you know,
because you might say,
well you might have benevolent motives
in establishing order,
but order shades into tyranny and then
your,
your motivations for establishing
tyranny might be completely self serving
and cruel.
You know,
there may be a process that gets you to
self serving and cruel certainly is what
happened with the Nazis.
And the question is,
was that they're all along.
Was it something that emerged?
Was it like the snake in the garden that
was going to present itself?
Well,
and you have Hitler on,
on the right there.
And that's a Nazi art statue behind it.
And you know,
it's kind of got this quasi Greek
element,
although,
and the Hitler was an admirer of
classical statuary,
but then everything's exaggerated about
it.
There's this sort of hyper masculine,
well it's like hyper masculinize Greek
sculpture that was the part of the Nazi
aesthetic.
So that one on the left says one folk,
one country,
one leader.
That's what fear means,
you know?
And so there you see that Hitler's head
is assimilated to the idea of a country,
right?
So it says this is,
there's something about this country
that's Hitler's hand.
So like you might think,
do you ever use symbols like that?
And the answer is,
well,
it's sure every time you give someone a
coin,
right?
So Hitler's head is like the head of the
realm.
And so what does that mean in,
in some sense it means that the realm is
an embodiment of Hitler or it's an
embodiment of the leader.
And actually around me is the embodiment
of the leader because it's a body of
laws.
And so what it represents is a mode of
being.
And so that's what that expresses.
And then you have him on the left there
and you know,
you can kind of see what sort of
emotions he thought were morally
appropriate.
And so it's almost a career teacher,
except there's about,
there's an element of seriousness about
it that's that that stops it from being
a caricatured.
And so what do you have to say about
that picture on the right?
What does that say to you?
Yeah,
yeah.
So those are all positive things so far
aren't they?
Could be argued to be that.
You see anything that isn't like that
there's some disdain.
Yeah,
that's right.
Who said that?
Yeah.
It seems,
I agree.
There's some disdain.
It's partly the narrowed eyebrows.
It's partly the fact that his face is up
a little bit and disdain is associated
with contempt and disgust.
Yeah.
And so I would also say there was some
arrogance in that.
Partly it's the sideways pose,
you know,
cause it's a real pose.
And so
I'd almost say I looked at it and I
think you almost answered that.
Normally he kind of touches ugly,
scary.
But this one's almost like timid little
boy.
I grew up,
well I think one of the things that I
think you can see in the picture is over
compensation.
You know,
because you shouldn't be any more
dominant that is necessary,
but you really have to be well put
together not to be more dominant is
necessary.
And I think the dominance is a
compensation at least in part for
childhood inadequacy and weakness.
That was actually one of the central
axioms of Adler Adlerian theory.
You know,
that what people were doing as they
progressed towards adulthood was
compensating for the inferiority of
their childhood.
You know,
and he said they'd often overcompensate
and you know,
if you watch your own behavior you will,
you could see that happening all the
time.
Happens all the time.
It's extraordinarily difficult not to
push any harder than you have to win.
Sometimes it's because you're trying to
look better than you are tougher than
you are.
And I think there is an element that you
can see in that cause it's like it's a
bit too much,
you know?
And I would also say,
one of the things I've noticed about
people who have really mastered
something is that they can do it with a
touch of humor,
even if it's really serious.
You know,
and I had this thought when I was
teaching this material probably 15 years
ago,
I thought there was a little voice in my
head that said,
well,
you know,
you should lighten up a bit.
And I thought,
what do you mean?
I'm talking about genocides,
like,
yeah,
I'm going to lighten up.
And then I thought if I was thinking
about young's notion of the,
of the gesture and the joker as a
precursor to the savior there,
there's this element of,
of subversion and humor that goes along
with attempting to crack a difficult
problem.
And I,
I thought about that for about five
years and I thought,
no,
it's right.
If you,
if,
if there isn't
okay,
if there isn't something that's akin to
the sort of thing that a comedian does
when you're talking about something,
then you're doing it too seriously.
It means you haven't mastered it.
You can't do it with a light touch.
So,
and I think you can see that in him.
Well there's,
there's one on the left there that's
Hitler for president.
So what do you,
what do you see in that
clear direction?
Yeah.
What else?
How would,
how,
how is there an indication of clear
direction is sort of posture.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
It's,
it's,
well,
it's very intense,
um,
perspective.
So there's a force moving upward and
he's at the top of the forest of the
lines go weirdly,
they go to the left,
which is quite interesting because
generally the way you would read a
poster like that is that harsh movement
to the left is regressive,
right?
It's backwards.
But you know,
you can understand why that might be.
And he's clearly the thing that sits on
top of the pillars.
Remember I showed you a picture of,
oh,
Cyrus,
you may not remember this.
That was all cyrus's hand on a pillar.
It's the same idea.
You know that his body is the body of
the state and the state has this
powerful movement forward.
Then there's,
this is an infamous picture this in the
middle.
So what do you think about that?
Oh yeah,
he's a knight.
He's a white knight,
in fact.
Yeah.
So he's assimilated to the idea of
medieval nobility,
you know,
and in its purest form,
he's a knight of the people,
you know?
And so,
okay,
there's a Wagnerian element to that.
And he was a great admirer of Wagner
Wagnerian music right away.
And Hitler wanted to put music halls in
every classical music halls in every
city in Europe.
It was starting to obsession of his,
he was obsessed with Wagnerian opera.
And he claimed that he had quasi
religious experiences listening to it,
you know?
So He's a very strange character because
Hitler was extremely,
appears to have been extremely high and
openness,
which is not something you would expect
for someone who was a tyrant,
you know,
because conservative people are
basically very low in openness and very
high in orderliness.
But he appeared to be someone who is
very high in orderliness and very high
in openness.
And I think that's one of the things
that made him charismatic,
you know?
So there's a deeply conservative element
and an element that was obsessed with
will and antithetical to chaos.
But he was able to bring this tremendous
artistic force into his pope,
politicking and it,
it was captivating to people,
hmm.
To what was conference Satori.
Yeah.
Well I think that's a perfectly
reasonable way of thinking about it.
But I also think he was open by
temperament.
And so one of the things that happens to
open people is that if they listened to
music that really captures them,
you know,
the hair stands up on the back of their
neck.
There they are experienced experiences
sort of ad hand,
you know?
And I also think it's very easy for
people to assume that if they're having
that experience,
that they're being inhabited by
something that's akin to divinity.
You know,
and you know,
you don't,
you don't want to make light of that
kind of experience because music is
incredibly gripping.
Almost everyone likes music.
You know,
some people like conventional music,
so you know,
they can tolerate a little bit of
exposure to the divine force of music.
Not much.
That's usually conservatives because
they listened to very conventional pop
music.
And then there's this wide variation,
but almost across almost all people,
music produces this influx of,
of Dionysian force,
you know,
really hyper conservative.
So band music and dancing,
right.
So because it's subversive.
So,
and then you have the one on the,
on the right.
So tell me about that one.
Especially the middle one that this
barely when facing the Friday.
So you can imagine you staring at the of
it and the next one is like light behind
him acting out like this.
You're going to save everything.
Yeah,
absolutely.
He's at the forefront of the heroic.
Um,
what would you call that?
It's enrollment formation.
Yes,
exactly.
He's at the very forefront of that,
you know?
And so yes.
Oh,
did say
no,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
Oh my
absolutely.
You know,
so,
but what's happening,
if you look at that image,
it's like that's Christ with the Holy
Ghost.
The Holy Ghost is represented by a dog
and that's often associated and
Christian symbolism with the Messenger
of God manifesting itself.
In some sense.
One of the deeper,
deepest Christian ideas is the idea that
when Christ died and left,
there was something left behind that was
still divine,
that could communicate with human
beings.
And that was partly outside at partly
inside.
Now the thing about Hitler is that it's
not a dove that's an eagle.
An Eagle is a carrion eater,
right?
It's a bird of prey.
And so,
and it's very interesting image because
you know,
you have to come to terms with the fact
that Hitler was a master of speech and
that made him a master of logos,
right?
Because that speech and communication,
but the question is,
you know,
that that seemed to be,
I think it's difficult to deny that that
was perverted in the favor of something
else.
And so the spirit that is coming out of
the sun and flying b behind Hitler is a
devouring carry on eating bird of prey.
No.
And that's,
and,
and you know,
people think eagles,
they're powerful.
It is the,
you know,
the national bird of the United States,
Benjamin Franklin recommended that it
would be the Turkey and everyone laughs
about that.
But you know,
it's worth thinking about.
Can't you also kind of say the Burger
right?
Would be like a felt in the chorus in a
way that he has this great vision and
sight?
Absolutely.
I mean
there's,
there's no shortage of it.
I've things about eagles that inspire
admiration in people,
but it's not a dove.
Yeah.
So the message and it's black,
not white,
you know,
so the message is quite,
when the flag itself,
those are the three primary colors.
Like if you look around cultures
worldwide and you look at names for
colors,
every culture has a name for black,
white and red.
And then after that the color is
fragments so that some are more
frequently named than others.
You know,
because you can start well yeah,
like his orange rand.
Well,
you know,
yes and no.
It depends on how differentiated your,
your,
your languages.
But black,
white and red,
you know,
that's fruit day and night.
That's one way of looking at her.
It's blood day and night.
So,
or it's rage day and night or war day
and night.
And so it's a powerful symbol.
It's also a sun symbol.
It's a sanskrit symbol,
but it's rotating backwards instead of
forwards.
So,
okay.
You know,
when the Nazis were very aware in many
ways of the meanings of the images that
they were using.
But I'm showing you this because I want
to show you how the archetypes were
captured by the propagandist
propagandists or hold the archetypes are
actually manifesting themselves in some
sense to produce the kind of powerful
grip that Hitler had over his audience.
And it was certainly the archetypes of
order,
the archetypes of heroism.
All of those are being put at the
service of a political ideology.
Riley's father images or individual
images.
Well,
they're both,
it depends on the image,
you know.
So in some images he's more like the
father of the people and other images.
He's more like the heroic Mara Duck at
the,
at the forefront of the march into
battle with,
with the illuminated God's behind them.
So,
and there's no reason for him not to
take on both symbolic aspects.
Like we know for example,
that as far as the,
as the Egyptians were concerned,
the ideal pharaoh was Hafele Cyrus and
half horace.
Right?
So embodied stability and also the
vision and the capacity to update that
stability.
So,
so this is actually counter propaganda
or maybe it's not,
maybe it's an attempt to represent the
part of Hitler that isn't being
represented by the German propaganda.
So on the left you have,
well those are Nazi snakes.
They've got swastikas all over them.
And so that's an interesting image as
far as I'm concerned because you see how
logical it is to use the image of the
knotted up snakes.
And there's a frog in there too,
by the way.
Snakes and frogs all nodded together,
makes a,
a representation of the enemy,
the evil enemy.
Like you get that at a glance,
right?
You don't need that bloody thing.
Interpreted.
Makes perfect sense.
You know when you see the same things
interesting.
And Leonardo,
I think I showed you some of the in
representations of Mary when she's
holding the infant out of the way of the
snake or the lizard that she's stepping
on.
It's a very similar idea.
And then you have Hitler's head there as
a spreading hydra.
You know,
he's sort of like a finger of death.
He's,
he's sort of like Ursula in the Little
Mermaid,
you know?
Except he's,
he's,
well,
it's not only a masculine image that
because the spreading tentacles that
snake like again,
and so there's an element of the Medusa
there that's a very archaic symbol,
you know?
And then you have another image on the
right there,
which is,
you know,
a graphical representation of Hitler and
his head is tangled up with the snake.
So
yeah,
you can see,
okay,
the reason those images have power is
because there
they're taking the power that's implicit
in the archetype and harnessing it for a
message that's been sent in a sense
actually what propaganda is like,
if you know the nature of the message
that you're using the archetype to
promote,
then it's propaganda.
If you're trying to figure something
else out and the symbolic
representations come to mind as part of
the creative process,
then that's not propaganda.
But then it also usually means that you
end up producing a piece of art that you
actually don't understand.
You know,
and there's still lots of renaissance
artists like that you like,
it contains information that we haven't
even come close to processing yet.
You know,
and I think most artistic
representations or you know,
partly propaganda and properly our pro,
partly art,
it depends on the representation.
So then on the left you have,
again that's,
that's anti Nazi,
that's an anti Nazi poster and you have
the idea of the dark figure lurking in
the background who sort of everywhere
gazing at you.
So that's like George Orwell's big
brother,
right?
So that's definitely harnessing the idea
of the terrible aspect of the great
father.
And I really liked this one on the,
on the right because that's basically,
well that's the virgin and child,
you know,
it's not a,
it's not precisely a Christian image.
It doesn't matter because that's not
precisely a Christian representation,
but she's beautiful and young and she's
holding something that's very vulnerable
in her arms.
And then you see these hands at the top
there,
um,
Nazi.
And at the bottom there,
Japanese,
because the symbols are on them.
And so one's coming from one end and
one's coming from the other.
And so what are the hands look like?
Hmm.
Well,
yeah,
but why,
why,
what,
how,
what makes them evil?
Shadows.
Yeah.
They have claws.
So they're predatory,
right?
And their wisdom.
And so they're sort of like death and
they're black.
You know,
the thing is,
it's so obvious,
right?
You know,
those are evil hands.
The question is,
why do you know that they're evil hands?
You know,
what is it about the image that
announces itself in that way?
It's also partly because of their
juxtaposition with the image of purity.
So that's really the absolute corrupt,
great farther reaching out for the
absolute perfect feminine and hero,
the baby hero and threatening that.
So there's some anti Jewish propaganda
on the right there.
So first of all,
the Jewish guy is represented as a money
changer and he's associated with the,
the Soviet Union because they,
they,
the onsies drew a tight relationship
between Jews and communism.
And so that was amalgamated into the
same kind of threat.
And then,
and certainly the case that Germany was
threatened by communism.
I mean there's absolutely no doubt about
that,
but say sort of lump their enemies into
one category.
And so what do you think about the
representation on the right?
What does it say?
I don't believe so.
A whole,
did you say?
Yeah.
No I don't.
I don't think so.
So his eyes are closed.
That's kind of interesting.
Um,
his hands,
his outstretched with money and he seems
to be,
I would say is hand head is oriented
towards the money.
Yes.
Is that,
is that right?
So I don't know what he's leaning on
exactly.
I don't know what that is,
but it's obviously not a flattery
representation.
And then you have the middle
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
There is a goal,
an element to that.
Do you want to explain what that means?
Um,
yeah.
It's like a Zombie.
Yes.
Carry out the will of the last
murderous.
Right.
So,
yeah.
so there's that,
there's a sort of undead element to the
representation.
Blind focused only on money.
Um,
you know,
and then also aligned with this terrible
destructive force of communism.
So another comment.
Yes.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Good point.
Yes.
So then there's the middle one,
then you see the juxtaposition of the
Jewish Star of David with the communist
hammer and sickle,
and you see the whole world on fire and
death emerging from that.
Right?
So there's a,
there's an idea of the ultimate call
apocalypse behind that.
There's an idea of hell behind that.
There's an idea of like the living dead
and,
and then,
you know,
and this is something that's sitting on
top of the world.
It's very say titanic image,
I think it says,
okay,
I don't know.
It's Bolshevik.
Part of that is,
and I don't know if there's an amalgam,
there is,
if is miss is a reference to Jewishness
or not.
I think it says Bolshevism unmasked.
It's something like that.
So,
you know,
and the idea that,
that the Nazis were anticommunist was
very powerful idea for people.
It made the morality of the situation
very murky in many ways.
Because for example,
when the Nazis went into Russia through
the Ukraine,
the Ukrainian started to fight with the
Nazis,
like alongside of them to get rid of the
communists because as far as they were
concerned,
the communists were worse than the
Nazis.
So you know,
it was a race to the bottom,
that's for sure.
And then it's so interesting because you
see the fire,
the destructive fire in the middle and
then on the left,
well those are crematoriums,
I believe they're from Auschwitz and
that those are the remnants of the
destroyed bodies in the ovens.
So you know,
all of that death and destruction was
being projected.
In some sense,
all the evil was being projected on to
the communists and the Jews.
And you know,
that allowed the exactly the same thing
to manifest itself in actuality in
Germany.
Well that's the laying out of the body.
So on the left and then that's Hitler
closer to the end of the war.
And you know,
he's looking pretty haggard and
his mouth is down and his countenance
has fallen,
which is a phrase that we'll encounter
next week.
Okay?
So you know,
you see this image of Hitler on the left
and he sort of friend to children with
the mother looking on happily in the
back and everybody's smiling and happy.
And then in the middle you see someone
who's been burned.
One of the things that happened when the
Nazis marched the Jews out of the camps
when the allies were coming is now,
and then they'd put a bunch of people in
the barn and light it on fire.
And I believe that that's an image from
that.
And then that's prisoner at the bottom
from one of the,
who didn't die from one of the Holocaust
counts.
So I would say,
you know,
the problem with the image on the last
okay
is that it doesn't factor in the image
in the middle.
And that's the thing about propaganda,
you know,
it's like,
it's all good.
It's like,
yeah,
no.
And if it's presenting itself as all
good,
then you got to ask yourself,
well,
where's the snake?
Cause there's always a snake.
And I would say the more [inaudible]
represents itself as pure good,
the bigger the snake.
So you know,
Dostoyevsky knew that when he started
writing anti utopian anti Utopian ideas,
especially in notes from underground,
he'd already figured out that if someone
was promising you haven't,
that the probability that there was a
hell lurking in there somewhere was,
well it was 100% so,
and part of the reason that I've been
working on the ideas in this book and
presenting them to people for so long is
I'm trying to inoculate people against
the temptations of Utopian thinking and
propaganda.
Because you should always be asking
yourself,
where's the other half?
If nature is all beautiful.
Well,
what about the destructive part?
You don't want,
if you're offering a utopia,
well,
aren't you also a devil in a tyrant?
Like what are you going to do with that
part?
You have what what you're gonna do is
you're going to say,
well,
I'm not the devil on the tire.
And it's those people over there.
It's like,
which only proves that you are in fact
both the devil and the tyrant,
but it's much easier for people to put
that out somewhere else,
you know,
because do you really want to deal with
it?
You know,
you said at the beginning of the class
you wrote out what horrible things might
happen to you if you didn't behave
properly.
And that's unsettling because you have
to recognize in yourself the capacity to
bring something like that about.
It's even worse than that because people
can bring that sort of thing about and
really enjoy it while it's happening.
You know,
in a really corrupt and destructive way.
It's a revenge.
They're looking for revenge and if they
have to take it on themselves,
that's no problem.
It just makes the revenge even sweeter.
Okay.
So there's juxtapositions again,
you know,
so I've got the crowd that surrounding
Hitler all happy at the dinner table
there on the left and then you know,
that's cartloads of bodies that were
taken away from the concentration
council and the allies came in.
So there's the tyrannical father and
the,
and the positive for other,
you know,
not I believe is from Nuremberg,
although I'm not absolutely certain
about.
So Nuremberg was the place where the
massive Nazi spectacles were held.
You know,
when you can see the Greek and Roman
symbolism there,
like the classical,
the idea that it was a reestablishment
of our enlightened classical society,
brilliant use of light against dark,
which something was something that the
Nazi as the beats were good at the use
of fire and light and black,
white and red contrast.
Very,
very powerful imagery.
I would say literature does great.
Literature does because it presents
people as the battleground between chaos
and order in good and evil,
every person.
So,
you know,
someone might be tilted towards the good
and in a great piece of literature,
but they're not,
they're not comic book Superhero,
you know,
and I mean,
even the comic books when they were DC
comic books,
that was pretty damn clear.
Superman,
he was all good.
The evils evil villains,
they were all villainous when the
marvel,
um,
what would you call mythologist sort of
emerged in the 1960s.
All the characters became more nuanced
and you know,
they're more palatable to I would say a
a martyred mind.
But also of course,
older people are paying attention to the
comic book characters now.
They're not for before they were for
like 10 year olds,
you know,
so they like,
they couldn't handle the complexity of
something that was more than one thing
at the same time.
But,
but like if you look at great
literature,
the heroes are often 51% good and 49%
evil,
you know,
and there's a tremendous battle going on
inside them and outside of them.
And so that makes it a lot more nuanced
and complex,
but it's also in some ways much more
frustrating to read.
So yeah,
so I would say the greater the
literature and the more it approximates
aren't the more balanced the portrayal
of the entire scenario.
So you have the chaos in the background,
you have the positive and negative
feminine and various manners.
You have the tyrant.
And the secure father,
you have the adversary and the hero.
They had the whole picture is painted.
You see the same thing,
I think in any great art.
So that's what makes it great.
Yes,
exactly it,
it did.
It tilts into either oversimplification
or propaganda.
So,
and it's dangerous,
especially,
especially when it harnesses the
archetypal forces.
So one of the things that's happened
since Nietzsche announced the death of
God is that political entities have
appropriated the archetypes.
We think,
well,
the gods are still in those archetypes.
There's no getting rid of them.
So the question is,
who's going to be using them?
And for what?
You know,
cause we think,
well,
we've transcended all that.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
You know,
you go see the avengers,
you know,
so you haven't transcended at all.
In fact,
you're more bone headed about it then
people were 200 years ago because now
it's comic book superheroes instead of
transcendent daddies.
I don't,
I don't see that as a consumption,
a conceptual improvement.
I see it as a regression.
So,
and that's a general who shot himself to
death.
A Nazi general,
you know,
win the victory of the allies was
certain and Hitler by that time.
Okay.
Basically the way Hitler rationalized
his defeat was the Germans let me down,
Berlin should burn.
And if the Russians come in and rape and
pillage the people who had happens to
deserve it.
So that was his final judgment on the
German people.
It wasn't that there was something wrong
with him,
is that it was that they just failed
him.
And so they weren't up to the glorious
task that he had set them.
And so they deserved all the rack and
ruin that was being visited on them.
So,
and when I look at that and I see what
happened,
Hitler shot himself in a bunker far
below ba Berlin when Europe was on fire.
Right.
Thing.
What makes you think that wasn't what he
was after from the beginning?
No one thinks that they think of,
well he know he wanted to build an
empire,
dominate the world and all those things.
It's like,
why would you think that?
Yeah,
there's an old psychoanalytic idea.
If you don't understand the motivation,
look at the consequences.
And in further motivation,
it's extraordinarily intelligent idea.
So you can't figure out what someone's
up to.
Okay.
What happens when they do whatever
they're doing?
Well,
if it's utter catastrophe and pain and
ruined,
you might think,
oh,
well there was some part of them that
was aiming at that.
Now,
you know,
you have to factor out the effects of
random chance,
but there was nothing random about what
Hitler did to Europe.
Quite the contrary.
You know,
when you might ask yourself,
why did he open up a two front war,
you know,
he wasn't historically ignorant.
You kind of knew by that point that
attacking Russia was probably not the
best thing to do if you actually want it
to win the war.
Now,
you know,
you could say that he was arrogant and
overvalued the,
the power of the,
of the Nazi war machine,
and it was two contemptuous of the
Russians and part of them,
no doubt.
Yeah.
Tell it that way.
But by the same token,
you can't suppress the suspicion that
the darkest parts of him thought that's
the fastest way to rack and ruin the,
certainly produced it.
Sure.
Yeah.
Why assume that the person is aiming for
what they say they're aiming for,
especially if they use means that are as
undeniably evil is anything you could
possibly come across top left.
That's Stellan.
And so there is an old guy kissing a
statue of Stella and a gold statue of
Stella,
and that's after the wall fell.
You know,
installing was an otter monster,
you know,
he made Hitler into,
he made Hitler
in many ways,
Hitler was a piker compared to style it.
And one of the very final things about
Hitler that's extraordinarily funny in
the worst possible manner is that one of
the only people he ever trusted,
sorry Stellan one of the people,
only people that still in ever trusted
was Hitler.
So we prepared,
he failed to prepare the Russian army,
the Soviet army for a potential invasion
by the Germans because Hitler said he
wouldn't invade.
And so when the Germans finally showed
up,
they just blew the Russians back.
They were completely unprepared,
you know?
And if the Russians couldn't have had
the Germans freeze to death because of
the winter,
there's little doubt that the Germans
would have overrun the Soviet Union.
I mean the Russians were tough and they
fought like mad,
but they were completely and utterly
unprepared.
So,
okay.
Okay.
So what we've been doing now,
like we're,
I want,
I'm kind of working towards the idea,
we're moving up the food chain in some
sense.
So we talked about chaos and we talked
about the great mother and now we've
talked about the great father and we're
sort of tilting up towards the final
level of analysis,
which is the relationship between the
individual and the adversary and then
the relationship between both of those
and the other levels.
You know,
and we,
we touched on that a little bit today
because we could see how Hitler was
presented both as great father but also
as you know,
heroic leader into the future.
You see the same thing with style in
there where he's shown us,
you know,
leader of the ship of state and he's far
as I'm concerned.
He's nothing different than captain hook
who's a tyrant.
Because he's afraid that he's afraid of
his own mortality.
He is afraid of the fact that the
crocodiles already got a piece of him
and turns them into a tire and he's
terrified of chaos.
Terrified of the positive feminine for
that matter.
And there,
you know,
you see,
well there's stolen,
you know,
the,
the farther of all Soviet people,
loving music,
friend to women and children,
you know,
and there's a statue of style and that
was toppled after the Berlin wall fell
and it's covered with red paint.
While you can imagine what that
indicates,
I really liked the one on the left,
that style.
I mean,
I look at that and I think you could
hardly,
if you were attempting to build a
representation of the devil himself in
developed in flames,
you could hardly do a better job than
that picture.
You know,
it's,
yeah.
And then on the,
on the left,
on the right there you have lennon in
the background and styling in the
foreground on the flag,
you know,
so those are the,
the two day at ease of the Russian
state.
There are what replaced God once,
you know,
once Nietzsche and announce God was
dead.
It was like,
okay,
well what's going to come up and fill
that void?
It's like,
Oh,
good.
It's Hitler and Lenin and Stalin.
That's a real improvement.
Okay.
That smile on the left there and you
know,
the estimates are that he was involved
in the death of about a hundred million
people,
so which you never hear anything about.
He was also a hero of the radical left
in the 1960s anyways,
we'll stop for now.